Jasmine so many fans are excited that
you and Gino are back for before the 90
days how are you feeling how are you
feeling ahead of the premiere I am very
excited as well you know uh I'm not a
rookie anymore so I know what is going
yeah if you could sum your storyline up
this season in one word what would it be
chaotic
chaotic yes that's usual for Jasmine and
Gino from what we've seen at least
I'm really worried you cheating on me
you're an idiot I'm gonna go my ex he
knows how to he's the best I have ever
had and in the trailer there's a moment
where Gino thinks you're cheating on him
and then it cuts to you saying your ex
was the best you've ever had
can you tease that moment first tell us
a little bit more about what what was
happening
and you know uh
people have different definitions of
cheating you know uh there is micro
cheating that is actual shooting that is
okay what you did if Gino did it how
would you react
I will be pissed I will be mad and but
my definition of cheating is like you
look another person you're cheating on
me okay so in using my own definition of
cheating I have to be fair to Gino he
say like you're cheating on me at the
moment according to my own definition
maybe maybe I was I don't know yet maybe
yes maybe not you have to watch the show
you're gonna be surprised uh but yes
that that I told you know what was very
very bad you don't tell that to a man
even if that was true or not that was
that was the lowest of the law you know
I reached from one point you know we do
the other in seconds yeah nothing very
explosive you always made me look crazy
I never said yes you do you're already
defending that God and you're comparing
me to her
hi
how has your Timber been and in your
jealousy
issues with Gino is that something
you're still working on have you made
any progress there
oh my goodness this is the thing you
know
um I have anger issues uh I I
have to admit it uh when I'm very mad
you know I reach a point in which I
literally feel like I'm watching a movie
I'm I'm the protagonist you know like oh
my gosh look at what she's doing now but
it's like watching a movie I cannot
control myself you know that sounds
crazy but that's the way I can I can
feel it it's like I just explode like
I'm super super emotional and when I'm
mad
I'm just like a volcano you know and I
say things that sometimes I don't mean
it and I have always been my dad and
that's something that I really dislike
about myself yeah you blank out and you
go there do you go to therapy do you go
to therapy for it I've been in therapy
I do everyday uh even by myself I
I've been provided many tools and all
that but well uh it's it's hard it's
it's not easy to be me you have to say
that or deal with me I'm a very
difficult person because as I said I can
go to both extremes that's kind of
dangerous yeah well the last time I
spoke with you you were doing a lot of
reflecting on your behavior uh you were
watching back your time last season
before the 90 days and you were pretty
hard on yourself what would you say
since then has been the one thing that
has changed the most about you well
um I know that I'm the worst judge in my
life you know I I know that and it's
it's very hard because I have this
tendency to believe that Perfection is
achievable when it comes to my
relationships with people and also uh
myself my physical appear Syrian
everything and that is it's a journey
that it's not like flat you know it has
its ups and downs I'm still a work in
progress there are so many things that I
I still have to work on and I'm still
judging myself a lot but I'm I'm more
aware of it and I try to be a little bit
more kind toward myself yeah something I
do admire about you is how open and
honest you are about your insecurities
and things you're working through when
you get work done you tell people what
you've got done why is that so important
for you and do you think you'll ever get
to a point where you will be okay with
just Jasmine that is my ultimate goal
you know to reach a point in my life in
which I I can practice what I preach I'm
always looking for Perfection and it's
very exhausting trying to look for
Perfection because it it doesn't exist
and yeah it doesn't exist it's not
achievable and I have learned that the
hard way and yes I'm very open about my
own insecurities because to a certain
extent you know it helped me to kind of
accept myself a little bit more the way
I am yeah as you should because it's
changing your idea about what perfect is
you are perfect as you are you know with
all my imperfections right with all your
imperfections right but we have to
actually live that way I totally
understand yeah fake it until you make
it you know I try even though there are
some days English because sometimes
people ask like oh you look so confident
like I am the most insecure person in
the world trust me I am I have never met
a person that is more insecure than me
but it comes because you know I have a
lot of baggage from trauma in the past
that I'm very aware of but I I feel like
it sometimes I I feel like just before
this interview I look at myself like 10
times in the mirror all my hair I wish I
had my hair extension on my eyelashes
I'm missing this and that you know these
are I'm always looking looking for for
something and it's very exhausting uh
but I'm trying just to relax a bit on
that yeah girl you should because when
you popped up on the screen I was like
oh my goodness you look so cute you look
beautiful and like you said we are our
harshest critic and you just gotta chain
you're seeing wrong that's the problem
you're not seeing yourself correctly so
the goal is that one day you will yes
hopefully yeah I'm working very hard on
it
um
it's a process but I I am not giving up
on on the idea of loving and accepting
myself just the way I am and I'm all for
being real and honest but stop saying
you're the most insecure person because
you say you know it has power you're
working on being more confident let's go
with that yes exactly I'm I'm working on
that well how is Gino how is he doing uh
he's doing great as usual you know uh
he's uh very different from me
um
his personality his very easy going he's
more like relaxed I'm like the anxious
person
like we balance each other I can tell
sometimes it's quite the opposite you
know but that's our Dynamic I've been
able to let the hats go yet no no no
that you you and viewers have to
understand something you know uh they
love that Dino has for his hats it's
irrevocable you know that's not gonna
stop that's the way he is he has an
infinite collection of ads I have never
seen a person owning so many hats
different styles now that's something
that you're gonna be seeing a lot system
is like the hats are there but they come
in different colors and shapes now okay
well during last season's tell-off or
you were complaining about the fact that
Gino likes to pleasure himself and
you're not getting as satisfied you
you're hungry and you want it
I'm vegan but I want your freaking meat
to give me the meat I want it maybe
that's the reason why I'm moving all the
time
I need some protein and it's some meat
yes yes uh well you know the lack of
action still a lack of action in the
bedroom still a problem for you too
we I can just tell you this girl uh
we're still having some bad issues uh
maybe not the same as before but uh you
know to me and Timothy is and I do
believe that for most couples not the
most important but it is one of the most
important parts because that's what made
you see your partner as your partner not
just like a as a roommate or as a friend
or as a colleague at work you know
intimacy actually changes the word
itself said it you know you need to be
intimate with that person and sex has
always been an issue uh for Gino and I
in one way or the
others so
l
El
sa
the doctor was just as confused as all
of us why Gino
what's going on with Gino what can you
tell us about that
I uh at that moment I was interest
um having a surgery in what I call
because you know I give a name to my my
flower you know I call it my purple Nana
so I want my purple NADA is yeah surgery
or not I just wanna clarify it is it's
good and it does the job you know I
enjoyed it and my partner too just want
to clarify that but you know
um I like to try new things and if I
have the money and the Chance why not
I Wanna Be virgin again so why not being
virgin again so that's the surgery that
I'm trying to get so what it is
basically reconstructing the hymen you
know because of course it got broken by
you know how the story you know and I
have kids and all that so they
reconstructed and
what the doctor is promising that it's
gonna be
tighter than it was even the first time
you know and I was like why not and it's
actually not expensive because I don't
know in in other parts of the world but
if it filled out from six dollars is not
something like super overpriced and very
very
affordable yeah okay okay